Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and all.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in to see how
your week's going. You know,
you know who I'm talking
about. Oh, you brave warriors,
you social justice people,
you know, misunderstood,
uh, you suffering white women
in your fucking SUV is, I just,
you know what you do day in and day out
is so difficult and I'm just checking in
to make sure that you're living your
truth and whatever else is written on your
fucking yoga pants.
How are you everybody?
I'm a New York City,
New York City,
skyscrapers and everything. Um, yeah,
I've been here for a couple of days and a,
I'm having a good time doing stand up,
you know,
even though it's like doing fucking
stand up at a woman's college now I can,
I have never, Eh, this trip,
I swear to fucking Christ.
I've gotten more grown standing
on stage doing my bullshit act.
Then I got my entire time when I lived
here for New York for like 10 years.
Like it's,
it's fucking crazy what has happened
to this comedy. This was one of,
this used to be one of the
great comedy cities. Oh my God.
Yeah.
You stand on stage.
You feel like somebody is like fucking
stepping on a puppy behind you.
You're like, what did I say?
What? What happened? Ah,
like the old time.
I am really holding on to this,
this hope that this is just a ridiculous
phase that this country is going
through this ridiculous phase where we
have allowed like 8% of the population in
,
they're unbelievably extreme lunatic ideas
to push us so far to the fucking left
at me as a lefty.
Like now I feel like,
do I need to start
watching fucking Fox News?
Is this where the middle is now watching
those costs on that fucking channel?
I mean I don't know what to do here.
Okay.
I Dunno. All I can tell you is when I
did stand up over in Europe, like the,
the level that they
were laughing at us for,
what the fuck we're doing because
we're all in a bubble over here.
I don't know what the deal is,
but I think it's a sad state that I
went to formerly communist Europe.
Um, and I felt freer to speak
over there then I fuck do here,
but it's unbelievable. Oh. Um,
but actually not in
defense of New York City.
I think I've been going
further in the grown direction
just as a reaction to it. Like, so I,
I could give myself some
space, you know, it's,
it's fucking claustrophobic. I
don't, I really don't understand.
I just don't understand adults
going to comedy shows and,
um, I don't know. You know what?
But you know, it was great.
Was the Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit that was fucking phenomenal.
And um,
actually one of the comics,
Mark Norman had a fucking
great joke on shit like that,
about people getting offended,
which I won't tell cause it's his joke.
So go out and go see them live.
Um,
thank you to everybody on
that came out this year.
I don't have the names in front of me,
so I know I'm going to forget somebody.
Michelle Wolf, Jay Oakerson, rich vos
hosting it for the seventh year in a row.
Mark Norman, Joe Lists, uh,
Gary Gulman, Chris read,
um, my mom and my mom. I
know I'm forgetting like
two or three people. I will,
everybody went out and
fucking killed. It was, uh,
you know, we got great feedback
about it. It was just, it's just,
it's one of my favorite things in
the world to do. And like I said,
all the money goes to
his mom and his wife and,
uh, you know, and people have asked,
well, why do you do it every single year?
You know, it's like boat,
which is one theater gig.
And Patrice was supporting those people.
And I always hated it.
When somebody dies. You do like one
fucking, you do it once. He like, Oh gay,
there's a sack of money. Try to
stretch that out for the next fucking,
I don't know, 20, 30, 50, 60 years
that you live in, you know. Um,
he was taken care of him. So,
uh, he unfortunately passed away.
So all the comics,
make sure that we were taken care of
who Patrice was taken care of. So, um,
like I said, all they should have to deal
with his degree for him not being here.
Other than that, you know, we should all
be helping them out, which we're doing.
So thank you from the bottom of my heart
to everybody who shows up to the thing
and everybody comes out and donates
their free time. Oh, Maureen Taren,
who puts the whole thing
together. Um, it's, it's, uh,
it's just awesome. So we're already
thinking about the lineup for next year,
kind of see if I can get Paul Versey, you
know, got to get very easy to come down.
Um, for some dumb reason, I
haven't asked him to do it yet.
There's always somebody every year.
I'm like,
why the fuck haven't I asked that
person yet? So, uh, that is the deal.
Um, anyways, let's talk
in the news. Oh my God.
You know, everybody is
talking about this, uh,
this Jessie Smith and Lewinski, whatever
his fucking name is. Juicy, juicy,
small, let Jesse Small that
everybody's talking about that.
But I don't think that's
the biggest news. And, uh,
the biggest story in the news right now,
I think it's as I on Williamson's Nike.
Okay.
The brand that Paul Versey love,
like it literally exploded on his
foot and caused him to have injury.
Now,
I can't imagine how many older white guys
like me with the dad bod that are now
going to reconsider buying Nikes because
if it can't withstand the power of Zion
Williamson, how is it with Stan? Me,
I'm trying to think of some dads.
Shit, I'm unfolding a stroller.
Oh God. Can you imagine what those evil
constant run Nike can you met that?
I bet they bet they have the
serial number on that sneaker.
And they attracted down that fucking
four year old that glued that thing
together. Oh my God. What are
they going? Oh, Jesus Christ.
Probably going to hang them upside down
for the next month by his fucking toes.
Yeah. Make them wear Adidas or
some shit. I don't know what,
but I can tell you something right now.
They are rejoicing at Adidas, Reebok,
uh, pro keds. Whoever else makes fucking
sneakers. I gotta be honest with you man,
that is like, I have not seen
a guy, this is Zion Williamson.
This if you Miss Bo Jackson,
like this is what you're watching.
Like somebody who just comes along.
Yeah. I mean he's literally
what the fuck this guy did.
Like I could not do that to a
sneaker if I got hit by a car,
I'd have to get hit by some farm equipment
and lose my leg for my sneaker to
look like that. That was just
the sheer strength of this man
making a cut or whatever. I
have no idea. But that reminded,
the only thing I'd ever seen like that
is you ever watched that shit on Bo
Jackson? How he ended up, um,
having that career ending injury is he
was running with such speed and had like
a 250 lineback pound linebacker hanging
on his leg as he continued to drag the
guy down the field and just,
it was weird.
It was like his own strength
worked against him because
anybody else would have
just fell down like a fucking sack of
potatoes and he continued to run with 250
fucking pounds hanging
on him. Um, unbelievable.
So I help that kids. All right.
I heard he is all right. Um,
I'm sure nobody on the tar heels side of
the fucking court was upset that he was
out for most of the gang. I think he came
back. I don't even know what happened. I,
I'm missing everything. Like my
Boston Bruins. Hey, we go bro words.
Here we go.
Um,
have one seven in a row and I've missed
every game. I've been following it. Um,
I heard there was a high stick goal that
we got away with against the La Kings
or whatever and uh,
so we ended up winning in overtime.
We just want in a shootout
against Vancouver. Um, you know,
big, big, big points.
Getting 14 points out of 14 points
this time a year going into March,
moving up the playoff thing. I
think we said they moved up to, uh,
the sixth seat or something like that.
Sweet 16.
I don't know what the fuck they said,
but all I know is what playing well.
So that makes me happy. And when I get
on the other side of my special here, uh,
I will be looking forward to maybe
take it in a game two. Um, all right,
so let's talk about Jeff.
Jesse smaller.
Jesus fucking Christ. I, I've been
watching this story just cringing.
You know, in the beginning it was
depressing. Like Jesus Christ.
Like why would somebody do
that to somebody? But then
when it started to unravel,
um, yeah, just like, oh no, please, no.
Okay,
please tell me you didn't do this to
your foot fucking guys on like one of the
biggest shows on fucking TV.
If this is true,
that's why I don't like talking about
it like, until it's like proven,
but it's looking fucking bed. What?
You don't, you know what I mean?
You know what's fucked up is everybody,
doesn't everybody have like
a hero fantasy, you know,
will you stop a bank robbery,
uh, stops up terrorists.
He ended up landing the plane or some
shit, and next thing you know you're,
you're on Oprah and she's talking to you.
Just go in like,
how are you so amazing?
And you're like, ah,
you know, shucks. I was just
doing my job as a passenger.
I did what anybody else you say of all
your rush shuck slides and then all of a
sudden you're like,
you wake up from the interview when
you realize you just drive it down the
street or you or you were talking to
yourself and somebody saw you, you know,
at least performers,
we're all a little bit nuts like that,
but to fucking follow through with it.
Then this guy ever watched the first 48
some of the ways they catch people.
Now I,
it's weird because I should be rooting
for them, but it's just, you just,
I watched some of these forensics
shows. It's like, oh, what the fuck?
You can figure it out from that.
I remember one time this guy suffocated
this woman using a fucking garbage bag
and they somehow found her, her
fucking face in the bag. Okay.
You know,
I gotta hand it to murder is the,
I don't know if they just
caught up on the emotion of it,
but like they're fucking belief in
themselves that they're going to get away
with this shit. They should really
just watch a couple episodes.
I like the first 48 or one of
these forensics fucking shows.
I don't know how anybody gets
away with anything, but um,
I got us, be honest with you now
that it's unraveling the bleach,
the maggot hat magnet, what does it
make? America great again. Mag a mag.
I had the fucking, uh,
the noose around his neck.
It all kind of reads like, you know, when
you do a first table, read up a script,
you know, you're like, ah, it's getting
there to get, he should've work.
Shopped it a little more. I would
have gone, would not have had the hat,
wouldn't have had the new, it's
it. Oh, the news. So whatever.
You know what it's like.
It's like, you know,
when one of the star
light goes out and they,
they accessorize too much and
then they go, you know what,
when it bright before you go out,
take two things off.
Like that's what he should've done.
Should've got rid of the
news and the fucking hat
and uh,
I don't get it.
The only thing that doesn't
make sense if this was fake,
like what kind of a fucking asshole
for 3,500 bucks is going to go to jail
and then have a hate crime on your
fucking record for the rest of your life?
I guess they were assuming that they
were going to get away with it. Um,
I dunno man. It's just the eye. Is
it weird? I feel bad for the guy.
It just reminds me when I was a kid and
I started lying to my parents and it's
just fucking got out of
control and then it's all,
you know what it reminds me
of. Okay. This is a true story.
I'm going to show you my,
my Jesse's,
we all got a little Jesse
similar smell let in us. Right.
Okay. So one time when I was in my
first year of first grade, right.
I loved it so much. I did it twice. Um,
when it came to school,
I was like,
that fucking hurdler who just hit the
first fucking hurdle and fell on his
goddamn face in the fucking race
was just over, you know, that was,
that was my school career. So anyways, um,
that was one of the
first jokes I ever wrote.
Talking about the second year of first
grade, how fucking boring it was.
Cause you learn how to read
and you literally learn how
to read the first grade.
At least you did back then.
So I remember like the first three months
being bored out of my mind is these
kids was sounding out the words.
They would sit next to me going like,
Duh,
Duh Duh.
In my joke on my hack was duck,
the word is duck to matter.
The picture didn't give it away.
That was my first really decent laugh.
I've got my laugh. Am I act? It was,
it was clean.
People thought I was on my way to doing
the tonight show with Johnny Carson.
That's how long ago this
was. Um, so anyways,
that was in my first year of first
grade and there was these two twins.
All right. And I had a crush on
one of them. Her name was Gwen
and I can't remember the other
one's name. Right. And, uh,
so anyway, I think I might have told
this story before on the podcast. Right.
But so we're fucking, um, Aman,
she's not in my class.
I'm in the other class with the sister
and her sister had this giant pink pen.
Like,
I dunno why it was like,
like if it would be like the size of a
number two pencil for like fucking Andre
the giant. I don't know why she had the
giant thing and for whatever reason,
you know, I just looked at, I thought,
I dunno, I just looked different.
I thought it was cool. So she dropped
it on the floor and we had like,
all four of our desks were
like made into a circle.
She had like groups of four going around
the teacher and it fell on the fucking
floor.
And um,
okay.
I fucking picked it up. And like
an idiot, this is how dumb I was.
I pick it up and rather
than just stealing it,
I just take it and I
start writing with it.
Like in the same fucking circle is her.
So she looks
over at me, she goes, hey, that's
my pen. And I go, no, it isn't
like go, it's mine. So this is
where my Jessie's story starts.
If this guy's guilty, right. And
I stick with this fucking story.
She goes up to the teacher and she
goes, Hey, took my pen and I'm going,
no, it's, it's not her pen, it's my
pen. It's a giant pink fucking pen.
And the teacher just looks
at me and she goes, you know,
I think it's so and so's pet.
I go, no, it isn't. It's mind.
And then she described this crack that
was in it, like to a t or whatever.
And of course I got busted
and the teacher's just
looking at me like, you know,
look at this little fucking Klepto Ron
Howard looking mother fucker, right?
So whatever, you know, you're a little
kid, you blow it off 10 minutes late,
you're probably talking to the person.
You just did that too. But anyways,
so the next day I go to school and
in between, like during the class,
they went to go to the bathroom. It
just so happened that girl, Gwen,
that I had the crush on, she
just looks at me. She goes,
I heard what you did to my sister.
She had this fucking look on her
face that she fucking hated me.
And I just turned around and walked away,
heartbroken to the, uh, to the bathroom,
knowing that the first girl I had a crush
on now knows that I'm a complete piece
of shit.
And that was probably the first stepping
stone on me becoming a fucking lonely
comedian. I don't know how
that ties into this, just,
just these small epit this, oh my God,
I can imagine that's a fucking felony.
I didn't know that.
Fake in a police report.
I that act and nonetheless,
yeah,
he almost satis speckles
they don't do that.
Um,
I guess it makes sense that the cops
would be pissed if you fake something like
all the fucking work they gotta do,
you know what I mean?
Putting this whole goddamn file together
and like this shit doesn't make sense.
It's like haven't write somebody a term
paper for you. And it's like, oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. Just fucking with you.
I'm not going to pay for that. And uh,
I'd never really had to do a term paper
and what the fuck was I doing over here
for the last God damn three weeks.
Um,
anyways, I got nothing to talk about.
I am so fucking lonely right now.
It's fucking ridiculous. Um, but my, my,
my wife and kid are going to be flying
out and meeting me soon. I can't wait.
Thank God for facetime. All I do is
sing baby shark. Get my kid going.
You know.
And then it's funny too is
I say this thing like she
always goes push the button,
push the button cause she wants to
hang up. So I just go, don't do it.
Don't push that button.
She gets this big grin on her face. She
loves nothing more. And right as I see,
are about ready to laugh. Her face
just disappears and then I become sad.
Anyways, Karl Lagerfeld died
according to the New York Post.
Jesus Christ.
I know that.
How sad and pathetic as this podcast
right now it's saying it's his cat might
get millions. I've be honest,
man. You think I trash fat people?
You should see fucking Karl Lagerfeld,
Lara field, whatever his fucking name is.
Um, he's just of, he was,
I guess he was a fashion giant than he
was very impressed with themselves. Um,
all right.
Somebody is about to get a golden litter
box among those who could inherit a big
hunk of the designer.
Carl lager fields are
$125 million fortune is
the love of his life.
His celebrity cat,
is it show pay?
Is that how you say his show pet is on
an American would say Cho pet show pay
all,
um,
Lagerfeld 85 who died Tuesday in Paris
made it clear in the past that his blue
eyed Berman kitty meant so much to him.
Uh,
that she would find a place in his will.
Yeah.
We probably knew like this
to cats live like 18 years.
You get one when you're 71 or whatever.
Now wait,
he was 85 probably got this
thing when he was like 80.
He's probably be like, well, this
thing is going to get fucking put down.
That's not going to happen. This
guy's a good shit. You know?
I know he trashed fat people in short
men and all of that type of stuff.
I thought he was fucking hilarious.
You know,
there's a few people out there that I
think should have been stand up comedians
instead of what they did,
even though they were wildly successful.
Like both those brothers
that are in oasis.
I half the shit I read that they say,
I like,
this shit's funnier than
anything I've ever fucking said.
These guys really should put down their
fucking Ukuleles and they should go on a
fucking standup tour. I'm not saying they
don't love their music. I'm just saying,
and this Karl Lagerfeld, some of the
shit that this guy said, it's like,
just look up at this
guy's quotes. He was, he,
he was like so fucking
mean. It's funny, you know,
unless you live here and
then you're triggered and
then everything needs to stop
and we up the fucking do you know,
I know I have a friend of mine,
somebody said to where it
said, uh, you know, hey,
you know I'm really hungry.
I'm going to go get something to eat.
And she wrote back, she goes,
me too. And then she wrote,
not me too with like the Hashtag ha ha ha.
And then the friend got all offended.
Like, that isn't funny. You shouldn't
joke about that. If we joke up,
it's like between each other, you're
fucking idiot. Nothing's happening here.
And she literally had to talk this
person off of a fucking emotional Ed like
ledge. That's where we're at. Okay.
That's where we're at in
this country right now.
And maybe that's why in
this current comedy climate,
somebody like this fucking poor pastor
decided to fucking fake this goddamn
thing, I guess. You know what,
they give you a shit cause they could
actually be out there solving real crimes.
They you go build that only took your
fucking 20 minutes to figure out,
okay.
Oh I could have been working
on this domestic violence case,
but I was this and it also probably had
like this high level of like priority.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. Is this going to
make a great made for TV movie?
You know what
I think considering magnum P
I's not a white guy anymore.
I'm throwing my hat in the ring to play
Jessie Smollett in this, uh, you know,
just a balance shit out.
All right.
If a, why didn't they give one in?
They give magnum a new fucking Ferrari.
Why is he still driving around in that
fucking thing? You know, that's one of,
there was one of the worst
Ferrari's ever made. Why can,
why can't you give the guy a
nice ride? You know? Does that,
does that make sense to anybody? I was
so far. I mean, I liked it as a nice,
cool that should be like his fucking
weekend driver. You know what I mean?
Like that was his high school car. So
he kept it or maybe like, I don't know,
maybe Tom Selleck fucking saved him
from drowning. And when he was a kid,
right after he bang that
chicken, the bikini, you know,
from the opening credits,
then he's like, oh look at this. I was
bagging you hear in the sand and there's,
there's a little fucking kid out.
They're drowning. When are you saved him?
He takes him in now the world don't
move to the beat of just one drum.
We're stuck here on this island,
but we're having fun. Right.
Right in the Ferrari.
You can sit on the fucking console.
Cause I got some hot ass sitting
in the passengers to see, um,
then he could have taken
over the business. Right. You
just have Tom Selleck, uh,
you know, his character dies. It's how I
would've done it. His character is dying.
You know, you make it like
somehow like a hot button issue.
Like he dies of like a, I dunno,
I dunno what prostate can't,
nobody gives a shit about prostate cancer.
He dies of male breast cancer. Okay.
In October.
And the NFL recognizes it by having pink
mustaches put on top of their helmets,
like looking like Lyft drivers.
Okay.
In his dying words or tells this kid to
take over the business and he's like,
and I want you to take care of my
car, make sure she's okay. Right.
So on very special assignments.
No,
whenever he takes a woman out on the
show, you know, I'm sorry, a warrior,
a brave, courageous, so brave
to get in those tee tops.
Uh, that t top car and then he just takes
them up at it. But the rest of the show,
he has a brand new fucking Ferrari,
you know,
they chases people down in the street.
And that's how I would've
done it personally.
Okay.
I don't want, I don't want to, you
know, I'm not trashing the show.
I'm just saying, you know, it's a network
show. I know you've got the budget.
You could have hooked the guy up with
a new Ferrari. All right. I Dunno.
I'll probably taken all this
shit to fucking seriously. Yeah.
I watched that show is, I didn't know, I
didn't know what was up. What was down.
Higgins is a woman now or I, I don't
get it. That's like the new thing.
You just do something that's already done,
but then you just switch everything up.
Yeah.
This used to be a black guy and now
it's a apparent, this was a white guy.
Now he's Puerto Rican. This was
a guy, now it's a woman in a,
it's the same fucking show.
You know what they're doing right now.
They're doing what Hanna Barbera did
with all of their fucking cartoons with
Hanna Barbera. God bless them
because they did Johnny quest,
my favorite fucking cartoon of all time,
but those motherfuckers plagiarize
themselves like 58 fucking times.
They had the Scooby Doo than
they are the Scooby Doo rip off.
They had the Flintstones,
which was a rip off of the honeymooners,
and it was just placed in the stone age
and then they did the sort of did the
same fucking show in the
future with the Jetsons.
I forgot. I had this all mapped out,
how they fucking rip themselves off.
And then in the end they combined all of
their characters and had these cartoon
Olympics called the laugh Olympics,
but somewhere. But it was all worth it.
It was all worth it because
of jinx the cat and uh,
and Johnny quest. All right.
And with that, let me read a,
let me read this here.
A quip.
One of the most important things we do
for our health everyday is brushing our
teeth.
Yet most of us don't do it properly.
How do you not do it properly? I
mean, it's fucking, it's right there.
Slide your tongue across your teeth. Does
it feel gross? Which one feels gross?
Brushed that one extra quip is a better
electric toothbrush created by dentists
and designers. Finally, they consulted
the dentist. They got the pros in there.
Quip was designed to make brushing
your teeth more simple, affordable,
and even enjoyable.
Mm.
I love this sensitive sonic vibrations.
Sorry,
I have to do the sound effects here.
This is a very low budget.
Read gentle enough on your sensitive gums.
Why people brush too hard.
And some electric toothbrushes are too
abrasive. They could explain that better.
If you brushed too hard, you're actually
gonna slowly wear away your gum line,
which is going to lead to a,
a a periodontal issue because what
happens is is that enamel is on the party,
your tooth, that that lives above
the gum. All right below your gum,
it doesn't have any enamel because
it's supposed to be covered by the gum.
It's protected there. So then when
you start brushing too hard, um,
you wear that away and eventually that
part gets exposed and it's way more
susceptible to tooth decay.
Then what happens is eventually you're,
you're looking at a crown or a root
canal or God forbid you lose a tooth.
Now when you lose a tooth,
okay,
you have to go to the fucking dentist and
you have to get something put in there
because what happens is,
is the teeth next to it move to the side
to try to close up the space and the
tooth directly below it will erupt upwards
to fill in that fucking space to help
fill it in. And then when it
erupts upwards, you got that party,
a tooth that doesn't have an AML on it
and that's exposed and then you lose that
fucking tooth and then everybody
starts fucking moving around.
It's a fucking shit show.
You know what it's like.
You ever seen those special
forces when they, they,
they got a hold the fucking log up to
become like an army ranger and have one
guy fucking quits.
Then they all the other fucking guys,
then they have to hold his weight
up. They don't get to quit, right?
It's kind of the same thing.
But anyways,
it's a built in two minute timer that
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you when
to switch sides,
helping guide of full and even clean so
you can be an absolute fucking moron and
do it properly. Uh, up to 90% of us
don't brush for a full two minutes.
I guess. I don't, I guess I'm
a moron or don't clean evenly.
A multiuse cover mounts to your mirror
and amounts to slide over your bristles a
for on the go. Brushing.
Say why you love quip.
I love quip cause they're paying me
to say it. That's why I love quip. No,
I love anything,
anybody to be honest with you.
Anybody that's helping you
take care of your teeth.
It's the number one fucking thing.
So number one goddamn thing,
you take care of your teeth like I like
what you're going to do for yourself in
life. All right? You chew
your food properly. You don't
have your fucking teeth,
you're not going to do that. It leads to
stomach problems, leads the gun problems.
Then you got problems in your
ass and next thing you know,
if people are coming by on your deathbed,
all right?
Or You could just buy this toothbrush.
That's why I love quip and why
they're backed by over 20,000 dental
professionals. Quip starts at just
$25 if you get up, if you get,
if you go to get quip.com burger
right now slash bar right now,
I could read that better get
quipped Q u I p.com/burr.
Right now you get your first
refill pack for free with quip,
with a quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill
pack for free and at get
quip.com/bird geet Q u I p. Dot
com slash all capitals, B u r.
R. Um, but you are our,
sorry, hiccup there anyways.
Um, is that it? Is that all
that I had to talk about? Um,
tonight I will be a,
I'll be at the west side comedy club
doing a little bit of time. Nothing crazy,
but I'm just going to be doing my set
until I fly over to jolly old England.
Make sure it's ready to go. And uh,
I'm starting to get butterflies, man.
I'm might go almost a week out.
Monday will be a week out and I'm getting
ready to take this thing and I am very
,
uh,
anxious to do it in a good way. I'm
nervous, but in a good way. And um,
I dunno, I can't, can't fucking wait.
CanNot fucking wait and I'm
gonna run the set tonight.
What else did I want to talk
about? Ah, fuck. I just had it.
See that you haven't and it
just goes away. You know why?
Cause I don't brush properly.
If I did two total when I brushed,
my brain wouldn't be fucking mush,
I guess. I have no fucking idea. Um,
anyways, it was fucking hilarious.
It's not really hilarious.
I was walking up the street and I was in
a good mood and shit and there was this
homeless person and she goes,
can you spare some change or whatever?
And I was like, yeah, I can. So I
suppose that might give a change.
I don't have any change. I'll give a
dollar. So as I was reaching in to, uh,
give our dollar, I would, I, you know,
I felt weird because I was just standing
there. So I was just like, hey, you know,
how's it going?
I said,
how's it go into a fucking homeless
person? And she just answered me honestly.
She's like, well, I'm living in a shelter.
My Dad died. And I was like, all right.
All right. Dumb question.
Kind of a fucking idiot in
my, you know, so how are you,
that's all I enjoy living on the street.
Did everything you thought
it was going to be?
Nope.
I don't really think when I speak before,
I speak a lot of the times and then I
say it. And as it's coming up, I'm like,
why did I say that?
You know?
But the good thing that I
have is I know I'm a moron.
I like to think this is one of my
better qualities is I know I'm a moron.
So as the person is fucking saying,
why did you say that?
I'm already agreeing with them. Like
I know, you're right. You're right.
I was stupid. So anyways, um, I hoped this
Jesse Smollett guy somehow makes
it come back. If this is all true,
Ilb makes a comeback from this fucking
shit. Jesus Christ. You hate to see.
I hate to see it. You hate to see it.
I've seen other people do shit like this.
It's just, I just, you fucking,
it's so fucking embarrassing.
It's fucking crazy to
take it to that lack of,
see if you just did this
amongst your friends, you know,
just tired one of your friends to punch
you in the lip and then you walk into a
party got jumped. But I fought him
off. Oh my God, he's so heroic.
And next thing you know,
you're getting blown. You know,
I can see the method of that madness, but
to take it to this fucking level, you,
you get to these fucking had gig come
over the little fucking little brush,
they start Dustin. Shit.
It's all gonna fall apart.
There's security cameras.
You can't get away with shit.
And now all these fucking people,
they're sending their DNA into these
goddamn things. It's, it's, it's,
it's a fucking rep.
It's a fucking rep.
Put my man, man voice back
on here. It is a fucking rap.
You're not going to be able to do shit.
And I'm not,
I'm not defended people doing
really crazy shit, but I mean,
you're not gonna be able do shit. You
know what I mean? Steal a Christmas tree
sophomore at shit.
Right.
Go around knocking people's fucking
mailboxes off with a baseball bat.
Stupid Shit. Yeah, none of
that. It's all going to be,
there'll be a fucking
drone following you around.
Somebody had some in the future.
I swear to God,
these robots are going to show up with a
little dusty fucking things that matter
what, no matter what
you do, you are at that
parking meter for all for 30 seconds more.
Here is your ticket.
But I got out of there before a cop
came. Shut up. We will eliminate you.
Speaking of elimination, the first
mammal, I don't even know what it was.
This little field mouse became
extinct because of global warming.
Cumin caused global fucking warming.
Ah.
Was the news going to talk about that?
I going to talk about that,
that I talk about it. Nah, talking
about it in the end. I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fucking solution is,
but I do know this.
When the water rises
up your flat screen TV,
you better get some flotation
devices for it. You know, you know,
it was gonna survive all the
people that live in the middle,
middle of the country. As the water rises
up, they're going to fucking survive.
You know?
And that's going to be hilarious watching
all the liberals who think they're so
fucking smart running from for the
fucking oceans rising. You know,
they're trying to hang out with all these,
get her done fucking people. All right.
That's a reality show that I,
that's not going to have to be scripted.
Um, anyways, why do I end up at such
dark shit? I always do this one.
I'm fucking alone. I just started
thinking about the end of the world,
I guess I just saying I missed my family.
All right, I'm going to stop babbling.
Um, God bless all of you. Enjoy
your weekend. You fucking cunts.
And I will, uh, I will check
it on your argus. I Dunno.
I'll do another fucking Monday
morning podcast as I do.
I've got to figure out when to do it.
I don't know where I'll be.
I think I'll be in England by then.
Who knows?
Maybe I'll put on a phony accent
for you, Huh? Feel you deserve it.
Kidding? Of course. All right.
That's it. Please enjoy the music.
And then we have another half hour of a
Thursday afternoon just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast, greatest
hit episode. All right, that's it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's pilfer and it is the Monday
morning podcasts for Monday,
February 21st,
2011 I can't say that 2011,
2011 I fucking tongue gets
stuck to the roof of my mouth.
2011 say, um,
yes. What is up? It's Sunday afternoon.
I am doing this podcast because I, I am,
I am committed to finally getting these
things up Monday morning all around the
world. Unless you live in
Japan, but if you live in Japan,
you can't understand what the fuck I'm
saying unless you're a US troop and
you're stationed over there.
At which point,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
All right, what am I supposed to do?
Nobody in Australia complaints
and there's 17 hours ahead of me.
So stand down son.
Um,
I have a big day ahead of me.
The NBA, all star game is, is,
is fucking at the staple center,
Staples Center home of the Los Angeles
Lakers and they're 11 championship
banners and then that one banner
with all those ones from the BBA.
So anyways, you gotta be
saying to yourself, hey bill,
you're a big sports fan.
Are you going to go to the game?
Yes I am.
I am going to go to the game.
Can you fucking believe it
kind of came out of nowhere.
All of a sudden I had a hookup.
Somebody came through with the ticket
and I said, apps a Fuckin lutely.
Somebody I know came through with the
fucking ticket for the entire all star
weekend yesterday for the three point
contest and the dunking contest.
He said, it starts at five 30 I'm like,
fuck, I'm flying back from New Jersey.
I land right about six and the
guy's like, oh, just come on over.
You'll get to catch the last
half of it. I said, great.
I go to get on my flight chief
and he very full flight people.
If you could not stand in the aisle,
could you just can't find you sheets
so we can expedite the fucking playable
blow of the turmeric and I'm sitting there
going, let's go. People fuck them on.
Sit down, sit down. Let's go. I finally
got a hookup. Let's do something.
Let's get this bitch off the ground.
And one of the,
what's the first thing that they say?
I'm praying,
praying for a nice 200 mile an hour
tail wind or whatever the fuck I need to
shave off a half hour. This son of a
bitch. And what do they say? They say,
we haven't very phone flight and a
captain got on and he starts talking about
how there's some fucking biblical level
headwind that's going to slow down the
plane, but we can try and make up the time
at a different altitude. Didn't happen.
They always stay.
We say that this fucking flight is going
to be about six hours and 15 minutes,
all right?
It doesn't take,
that takes about five and a half hours
with a usual goddamn headwind. Okay?
But they say six hours and 15 minutes
just in case there's a delay, you know,
take off or landing or whatever.
They can still say that they're
on time and if there's no delay,
then they can be like, Eh, we got
you in here about 20 minutes early.
Like we can't do the fucking math.
Like we don't know what they're doing.
So it turns out this is fucking insane
headwind and an ends up taking seven
fucking hours to get to lax.
And by the time I landed,
I didn't even want to go.
I didn't even give a shit.
My fucking knees were fucking
behind my shoulders at that point.
Just cramped in there, you know an
idea. I said, fine, I'll gives a shit.
You know that Dunkin contest.
I can watch all of that on Youtube,
but I'm still going to the
fucking game. Um, and I'm psyched.
I've never been to an all star
game before. Never ever, ever.
And I'm psyched to stand there
and look at all the celebrities.
They're going to be there
and all their bitches. Huh?
I don't want to see the wives.
I want to see that bitches.
I want to see they a gold digger and
fucking whores. That's what I want to see.
Fuck the NBA players.
I don't give a shit about them.
Bunch of Goddamn Weirdos. You're all
six foot 10. You should be able to dunk.
All right?
And you look weird in street clothes.
Do you ever see an NBA player in a suit?
You know,
we looks like that they have like giantism
of something. They don't look right.
They don't look right unless they're in
a tank top and shorts standing next to
another guy who's also
six foot fucking tents.
I don't give a shit about those guys.
They don't give a fuck about me, right?
I'm there to see the gold digging whores.
I want to see that whole
fucking game going down.
Right? Okay. It's the All Star Games.
You know all these celebrities.
They got to bring their bottom bitch to
that one. They got to bring their wife.
They got to bring this serious girlfriend.
That's what the fuck they
have to bring. All right. The,
she's in the pride,
but on the outside,
little fucking hyenas trying to
steal a little piece of meat, right?
That's going to be all the
horse. That's the game. That's,
that's the fucking game
I'm going to be watching.
I want to see what ridiculous fucking
outfit the gold dig and horror is.
Gonna is gonna fucking be wearing the
length that she's going to have to go to.
To get this,
these fucking multimillionaires,
to notice him right in front of their
fucking wife. I can't wait. I cannot wait.
You know what? I got an idea. How about
it takes some pictures. I'll take some
do that. That goes against everything
that I'm about. I can't fucking do.
I can't rat out people. I can't wait.
That's what, that's what I want to see.
I want to see that and absolutely no
defense. You know, one 72, one 68 games.
It's going to be fucking awesome.
I can't wait and uh, and that's it.
So believe it or not, I'm actually in
a great mood. I had an awesome weekend.
I have no funny stories to tell
everything. Everything worked out.
I did the Tarrytown, a music
hall and Tarrytown, New York.
Beautiful,
beautiful,
full, lovely, safe, creepy, scary
white is fucking town ever. You guys
ever been to West Chester, New York?
There is a level of wealth,
a level of whiteness and a level of
overall piece yet unbelievable fucking
to that part of the country. I can
see. I'm tried. I tried to explain.
I was talking about it on
stage and people were laughing.
I couldn't tell if they were just laughing
because I was in that town making fun
of it. But like Terry towns,
like ridiculous. It's like,
yeah,
these, these, I mean you could
shoot a period piece there,
some Charles Dickens novel. If you
ever wanted to turn it into a movie,
you could very easily just remove all
the cars and just dress everybody up.
Like it was a 17 or 18 hundreds and just
have them going up the street and a God
damn horse. It wouldn't be a
fucking problem. Put it this way,
the next town over is sleepy hollow.
All right. Headless Horseman Shit. Okay.
And right next to that is
the Hudson River. All right.
And which is eerily quiet at
night and a little bit south.
You've got the Tappan Zee bridge, the
whole thing. It looks like you're on.
You feel like you're on a movie set.
That's what I was joking about,
that everything just felt so wonderful,
peaceful and safe.
And you felt every time
you turned a corner,
you felt that there was just going to
be like a hundred zombies just standing
there and then they'd look at
you. You know, when they get that,
that excitement that they see fresh meat
and I don't really happen to zombies,
but all of a sudden they can run now,
which is pretty fucking awesome unless
you're getting chased by one. Um,
that was the vibe of, of, uh, of
Terry town. But I went in and I did,
did my show. And you gotta understand
like I did that theater like five,
six years ago as part of a tour
for the Montreal comedy festival.
And I was on that tour with like,
like six or seven other comedians.
So all I got to do is like 15 minutes.
And I remember I was excited then
to be doing it. And you know,
you start thinking like,
man,
am I ever going to be able to play this
place on my own? It was fucking awesome.
They showed up and the place was packed.
And then the next night was,
uh,
the count Basie theater in Red Bank,
New Jersey. And that place was gigantic.
And the second, you know, we booked it.
I was paranoid that they're going to
have to cancel it or I don't want you to
only be like half fucking full. And that
one ended up fucking selling out. And, uh,
so I just want to thank everybody and
creepy ass Tarrytown, sleepy hollow,
Westchester County who
showed up to my gig. Um,
and everybody out in New Jersey now,
people fucking sleep on New Jersey,
by the way,
you know,
because all they do is they come out of
Manhattan and they jump on the Jersey
turnpike and they see all those
chemical fucking plants and uh,
they just think it's, it's a
shit hole. But I'm telling you,
there's some absolutely gorgeous
parts of it. And Red Bank,
New Jersey was one of them.
Like I saw,
have you ever seen what a $20 million
home looks like? You know, live.
I've never seen it. It's, it's it.
It's like these fucking people
live in houses as big as schools
and you know,
and as much as they were beautiful
and as much as I was in awe of them,
I just remember thinking,
how could you possibly do,
have done anything remotely legal
together, that fucking house,
you know, I'm telling you, I swear to God,
I bet 90% of them were
bankers and people in finance.
I'm telling you.
And then the other will be like the,
Oh that guy created a then the mutant
Ninja turtles or something huge.
But other than that,
if you're just a regular fucking person,
the only way to make that
kind of fucking money
is you've got to be in banking.
Fucking genius.
Whoever came up with the idea of a bank,
hey everybody,
you guys work all week and then you
give you money to me. All right.
Then I'll pull it all together and I'll
loan it back to yet interest and then
you give me more money on that while
you continue to give me all your other
money every fucking week.
Don't worry, I'll keep it safe.
You piece of shit, motherfucker.
You fucking kidding me.
Well, how do you justify, how do
you earn enough fucking money?
Yeah,
I could see if Derek Jeter add one
of those houses, I get it. I get it.
He fucking shows up to a stadium and
60,000 people show up. What do you think?
What would have happened if they said,
hey,
a bankers giving a
lecture at Yankee Stadium?
How many fucking people you think
would show up fucking asshole?
He probably couldn't even
fill up the stress factory.
You know?
That's what I swear to God. That's,
that's, that's my feeling when, when I,
the few times that I've gotten
into those types of areas,
I drive by them and I am in absolute
fucking are of the level of wealth.
And then that's immediately what I think.
Like there's no fucking way,
there's no legal fucking way to do this.
You know,
take it from me, take it from me.
I'm doing all right now. You know,
selling out theaters.
Let me,
you should see the laws that they have
to make sure that I don't get rich.
They are just, they're taking a
fucking machete to my knees right now.
When we do an impression of my, of me
talking to my accountant every quarter,
what do you gotta be? You know,
sat to this fucking country that,
that's 0.3 seconds.
But I get it. I get it. We're
fighting to fucking wars.
Somebody's got to pay for it and
it can be those rich [inaudible]
Jesus fucking Christ.
Anyways,
the fuck was I talking about? Yeah. You
know what it's like. It's like that,
that president over there in Egypt,
you know,
he was like a bank.
He had all their fucking money and it
was just sitting there. He took it.
Of course he took it, you know
something. I'm not even mad at bankers.
I'm not even fucking mad at him because
I think, well, I don't know. I can't,
I can't say money.
That isn't the thing that gets me going.
Women, I would say that you
got to pick your weakness.
Some people you'll weaknesses money.
Some people, your weakness, his power.
Mine is the fucking Bra.
I'll tell you right now,
if making people laugh ever gets me
to the level of being a dictator,
there is no fucking way I'm going to be
able to remain faithful. I will have,
who is, do you understand me? People I
will have fucking who was listening to me.
I'm going to the fucking NBA All
star game tonight. All right. And
um,
it's,
I'm more excited to see the level of
gold digging fucking whore that's gonna
show up the temptresses I can't wait.
I cannot fucking wait to see how high up
you have to Jackie a fucking ass up to
get noticed at the all star game.
Cause you know,
every horror out there is she's
going with the fucking four,
five inch Goddamn stilettos.
Ah,
walking down those, those, those fucking,
you know, they're all going to be sitting,
you know, where did gold digging whores
sit? The wives sit court side, they sit,
they sit in a group.
You've ever noticed that they all
keep the wives all you know, together.
It's a very smart move by the men,
you know,
cause you got a bunch of women together.
Eventually they're just going
to be running their mouths.
They're not gonna be paying
attention to shit. I don't
think we doing that shit while
the fucking games going on.
They don't give a shit, right.
I'd say the gold digging whores.
Yeah.
I'm going to say that they're going to
start at about row about 20 maybe 21 it's
a more believable number,
right? 20 was to even, you know,
wrote 23 that's where they're
going to start. All right,
and that's going to be like
the gold digging whores,
gold digging whore. You know what I
mean? Like the quarterback, quarterback,
the comic's comic,
the whores whore is going to be
at the NBA All star game already.
Bang in.
Somebody's already hooked up.
She's going to be about road 20 right?
She's already gonna have guilted.
Somebody down there,
somebody connected that you know,
how come your wife is sitting?
Seven rows in front of me and Aa.
I got to do what I got to fucking do
and don't worry. I'll make it up to you.
So she already has something shiny
coming her fucking way. All right.
And then you go back.
You Go,
you go up while staple is weird where
it's kind of the haves, the have nots,
you know, see if he get to the upper
deck, those are like the open miker horse.
All right?
That's someone who just
fucking blew somebody in a
ticket booth to get up to the
300 fucking level.
All right?
So what they're going to do is they're
basically going to be dressed and hot for
, uh, you know, I dunno, they're going
to be updated with the fucking, uh,
potato skin. Eaton sports bar guy, right.
The season ticket holder assumption.
I don't know what the fuck I'm consulting
things kind of unraveling all I know.
Is this going to be a bunch of fucking
whores down there and I can't wait.
I can't wait to look at him.
No, I've got, I've come to this
level in life where I, I really am.
I don't judge people. I know I'm saying
whores and gold digging. I, you know,
I know I'm saying that ship and I'm not
in a judgmental way. The same thing.
I don't judge that. The, the,
the fucking piece of shit.
I guess that's judgemental, but you
know, whenever I'm a piece of shit,
the piece of shit guy who was running,
shipped over there in Egypt, you know,
I get why he stole all that fucking money
because it was right there.
You know?
Right fucking there.
I mean,
until you are in that
position where you're,
you're at that level of temptation
till you faced it and passed that test,
you can't judge that guy.
Can you imagine that?
Just a mountain of cash just sitting
right to the right. Your lazy boy,
like a big bowl of fucking m
and m's and you guys out there,
you've got your little fucking m
and m's right next to your TV chair.
How many of those deed at night?
You know, you ever tell yourself,
this is the last handful. You tell
your kid, go right back for more.
You have a get it so fucking,
you know you're doing that thing where
you're making the fist and then you'd get
fucking dropping them out of the
bottom of your fists. You know,
like some fucking,
I don't know what,
like some Goddamn guppy feeding
at the top of a fish tank.
Yeah.
We're all gluttonous assholes and I'm,
I'm, I'm right up there with them.
I don't know what the fucking point was.
I'm just telling you I'm excited.
I'm going to this fucking game.
Uh, that's 17 minutes, 17 minutes.
How many fucks was that sir?
Um,
all right,
let's get on with the podcast here.
I want to thank everybody seriously who
came out to the, uh, Terry town. Um,
I keep forgetting the music hall and,
uh, the count Basie theater and a,
I'm going to keep writing jokes because
that was unbelievably motivating.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna
try to do that every, every year.
Absolutely phenomenal fucking,
uh,
experience. I have nothing bad to say
about any of it. And last week people,
I told you, uh, if you want to
become part of this podcast,
if you would like to participate,
if you'd like to comment on any
fucked up thing that I said,
if you'd like to introduce a new topic
or add to the topics that exist or just
vent.
We,
I have a new email streamline and getting
all the podcasts emails to one email
so I don't miss any of the good ones.
Is
bill@themmpodcast.com once again,
bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
And if you could do us a favor, if
you could just in the title, um,
in the, in the subject line,
could you just stick, you know,
under what category it's going to fist
fit if you have overrated, underrated,
if you want some advice. Um, is
it racist? Your country sucks too.
Um, anything, anything you
want to, you have a youtube
videos of the week, anything.
Just just right. Obviously
overrated. Youtube. Is it racist,
right in the subject line of really help
us to kind of streamline them cause I
actually have somebody now who's gathering
all of them and just sends them to me
one email and then, you know, I
just read through all of them.
I picked the best ones, the ones that I
respond to. So once again, you email it
bill@themmpodcast.com.
Um,
and that is it in the official podcast
of the Monday morning podcast is www dot
the MLM, podcast.com we
have all the youtube videos,
anything that I talk about, um,
pictures of theaters, anything,
and I'm talking about gold digging.
Who is,
we'll have pictures in that type of shit
so you can follow along at work right
before you slump over
and die in your cubicle.
Um, all right. I got a little
backlash this past week from, um,
from a number of things. One from, is
it racist and another number from, uh,
the two drink minimum. Let's start
with two drink minimum first. Um,
last week someone was talking about the
two drink minimum. Uh, why they have that.
A comedy clubs and I was trying to explain
that that's basically how the comedy
club makes money. So this guy says,
Bill, as I listened to the podcast today,
I must disagree with your diatribe on
the two drink minimum yet you love that
rather than my opinion becomes a
diatribe. I ain't went to, I tried means,
but that just sounds like made and seem
like I was going on and on and on. Um,
I agree.
That comedy club,
I agree that comedy clubs need to
make money. Well, thank you sir.
Thank you for extending me
that fucking olive branch.
I agree that sometimes they
promise certain payouts.
Okay. I wasn't asking you to
agree with it. That's how it is.
But the two drink minimum is the
equivalent of every other company's hidden
charges.
If the club needs to make money,
add $20 to the price of a fucking ticket.
People that don't drink have a real
issue being forced to buy drinks because
some clown can't manage
his business any tighter.
Whatever happened to
truth and advertising,
tell me up front what the entertainment
bill is going to cost me regards.
All right, whatever happened to
truth in advertising. Um, sir,
if you can tell me an era when there
was ever any truth in advertising.
Um,
I will give you a box of free DVDs.
There's never been any
truth in advertising,
and that includes you when you went out
to bars and you're trying to get your
dick sucked the way you made your job
sound a lot more important than it was.
All right? So get off your
fucking high horse right there.
That's the first high horse you have to
get off. All right? In a nice little you,
it's like you're fucking driving.
You ever see the Budweiser Clydesdale
fucking thing? You know that.
I don't know what it does. The stage
coach for the guy who owns Budweiser,
I never really understood what the fuck
that thing was supposed to be. But uh,
you have a team of Clydesdale
high horses here. All right.
The fact that you have to state that of
Goddamn business needs to make money and
that they actually promised to pay the
ax. I don't understand those points. Um,
and s okay.
First of all,
he's saying that a two drink minimum is
the equivalent of every other company's
hidden charges. There's nothing
hidden about the two drink minimum.
It's written on the fucking ticket.
It's on a sign inside the
club as you're walking in,
it's announced before the show.
Everything two drink minimum,
they actually have called comedy should
teach shows on TV to drink two drink
minimum. They used to be a show called
two drink minimum. You know what I mean?
It's like you'd saying that there's some
sort of hidden thing that a fire engine
is red. You go into a club, there's
a two drink minimum. All right?
What I think is really
going on here is you,
you don't understand the business
of running a comedy club.
All right? The, the, I don't
understand why you're saying,
why don't you, why don't you, uh, people
that don't drink have a real itch.
Everybody drinks, sir. Everybody drinks.
All right? You don't drink. You don't
drink it all. You don't drink water.
You don't drink soda,
you don't drink at all.
You don't have to buy a
drink that has alcohol in it,
but you have to buy a drink.
All right,
and you're getting mad at
the wrong fucking people.
You're getting mad at the club because
they're forcing you to buy drinks.
Why do you think that is?
Why do you think he cut
the club owners greedy?
The reason why they force you to buy
drinks is because of the amount of fucking
tightwads that show up to clubs and
go, can I have a water? Two straws,
police. That's the problem. All right.
See,
back in the day that probably wasn't a
two drink minimum because back in the day
the artists used to get unbelievably
fucked by the promoter, believe it or not,
back in the day.
This is like before free agency in sports
back in the day believer it or not,
when a band, a comedian,
any sort of entertainer,
went to a venue to perform.
The promoter got 80% of the door
and the artists got 20% all right.
But because of the brilliance and the
balls of Peter Grant with led Zeppelin,
as far as I know,
I'm giving him credit.
He's the first guy I read that finally
went up to the and said, listen mate,
they come in here to look at
the fucking building. Alright,
you silly cunt that come in here
to see fucking led Zeppelin.
I know it's a brutal, brutal British
accent, but he was the guy going, listen,
nobody gives a fuck about your building.
I could stick these guys in
any fucking building out here.
They're going to sell out because
they're coming to see the band.
So he was the guy who said,
listen,
we get 80% you get fucking 20% all right?
So the promoter has to make his fucking
money and he makes money by selling food
and drinks, all right? That's
how it is. But the problem is,
is people will go in there and they won't
fucking buy drinks or they won't buy
food. They'll go in there and they will
sit there and they will sip on a fucking
water.
That's why there is a two drink minimum,
which is advertised on the fucking ticket.
It is advertised.
They haven't on a signed before
you even fucking walk in there.
The you call up the comedy club.
They say there is a two drink minimum.
This show is 21 and older
with a two drink minimum.
I've heard that maybe 40 million
times in my comedy career.
There is no sort of false advertising
going on here, sir. All right.
That is why they have to make money,
dude.
Do you know much money it costs to run
a fucking club? Do you know much money?
It costs to get a liquor license.
You want to people,
you have to grease the
amount of taxes you have to
pay the amount you have to pay and
fucking rent. All of that bullshit.
You know what?
You don't.
I know a guy who opened up a fucking
theater and it was these union guys.
All right.
And to change the sign,
he had to hire two union guys,
one guy to go up the ladder,
one guy to hold the fucking ladder
and a cop to stand there and make sure
everything was fine,
was costing him like 1500 bucks to put up.
And this week come down and check out
Bob Saget or wherever the fuck was there.
So he had to sit there in lobby with
politicians and lobby with all these
fucking people and try and go around
unions and all this fucking horseshit just
so he could get a sign out front that he
could change electronically from inside
the building.
Do you want to stand that fifth 1500
bucks a week times 52 weeks a year?
That's just, if you just change
it once, forget about this guy.
The way he had it running,
he had a musical act and a comedy act and
then a musical act every fucking week.
So it's three times a week. That's
what, 3040 500 bucks. That's like,
what? 250 fucking grand a year to get a
guy to change letters on a fucking sign.
Okay. It costs money to run a
goddamn business. All right.
I don't know what else to tell you.
Okay.
But you getting mad at clubs for
having two drink minimums. It's,
it's, you know, it's not
the club. It's not the club.
It's all, it's the tight Fox sit next
to you. Who's going to bring cheese?
It's in and a little butter knife to
spread his cheese on and that shit,
you know,
I don't
fucking stay home. I don't know what to
tell you. I don't know what to tell you.
Uh, what else? Oh,
what are the backlash shake?
I've got to this week on the, uh,
the fuck was it? Is it racist? Went
back and forth with this fucking guy,
which was hilarious.
This guy was,
he wrote that guy last week who wrote
the thing where you said a bill.
Older Asian is racist as
shit. I'm sorry, but it is.
So I wrote him back where I was like,
well dude,
you kind of have to elaborate
on your point. And number two,
why are you apologizing?
That's kind of a pet peeve of mine.
I hate when someone does is agree with
you. And then they apologize. I'm sorry,
but your angst like, dude,
you're not, you're not sorry.
Why are you saying you're sorry?
What are you sorry about?
You're not fucking sorry.
Stop saying you're sorry.
So this guy goes on and on and on and
he proceeds to basically say that I was
playing on Asian
stereotypes. Um, and that,
and I had preconceived
notions about Asians and all
this type of shit. You know,
and I don't give a fuck if you
are just joking. That is racist.
I don't give a fuck how you meant it.
It's fucking race.
All that psycho shit.
And then he proceeds to prove
his point by then hitting me.
I Dunno what he,
the rest of his fucking email,
he was trying to give me examples
that my preconceived notions,
my alleged preconceived notions about
Asians was fucked up as he then dumps of
all his preconceived notions about
white people. He goes, really?
Are the Asians the only bad drivers?
What about all those rich
white kids denting their
dad's Mercedes on the regular
fucking Hilarious, you know? All right.
And then I just asked him to name who
those rich white kids were because you
know, I hung out with a letter,
wrote white kids growing up,
all white kids and none of them are dads
had fucking w who are these rich white
kids, sir? Where did you
meet these rich white kids?
Where you and your younger brother with
the fucking kidney disease adopted by a
rich white man? Is that how you
ran into all these rich white kids?
You're fucking generalizing. You're
doing the exact same horse shit. So,
but it ended up being a great
debate. And this is, this is what I,
this is what I've, I've, I've come to
realize about jokes when it comes to race.
I think I could be wrong here,
but I think they threw,
there's three categories when you do it.
When you joke in a racial way,
it can either a be straight up,
funny B,
be offensive or c be racist and it all,
and there's a bunch of
variables that play into it.
It plays in to the intent of the person.
If your intent is not
to be fucking racist,
what you said I believe is not racist.
What it is at that point is offensive.
You made a joke,
you thought it was going to be funny,
but people took it a different way.
They didn't find it funny.
They're saying it's racist.
You acknowledged just
fucking around and it's like,
well at that then it
becomes offensive I think.
All right,
and then it also comes down to your
relationship because if you know you're
fucking white and somebody else is
black or whatever and your friends,
the level of being offended gets
pushed way down the goddamn streets.
You know, to the point. Sometimes
if other people are listening,
they can't believe what the fuck the
two of you were saying to each other,
but I still maintain, it comes
down to intent now that older age.
Oh and and the social situation,
all the region of just fucking around.
It's a joke.
It's not racist because I don't have
any fucking bad feelings about agents.
It's just something for,
it's a funny fucking game.
I came up with driving and
traffic after I saw a pattern,
I kept getting cut off and it just seemed
that 80% of the fucking time it was
either some old due to some Asian dude,
so it was a joke.
I started playing that game with my
girl. What do you want? Older Asian,
what do you got? Put your money
on the table just fucking around.
Now obviously if I'm doing
that outside of the car,
I'm going to fucking offense.
I'm going to offend somebody,
but it's still not racist because
I don't mean it that way, you know?
I know a lot of people gonna fucking
disagree with that, but I truly,
you can't tell me what the fuck. I mean,
I know what I'm thinking. You know?
Does that fucking May, I don't
know. I don't fucking know.
But in the same thing is
that that older Asian thing,
Barack Obama couldn't be in the middle
of doing the state of the union. Go on.
We're going to get turns into country
around, we're going to do this.
We'll do that. And you
know what? You know what,
I like to play in the back
whenever my limo gets cut up.
I played this game called older Asian,
you know,
that's even that. If he's just fucking
around, I don't think that's racist.
It's incredibly irresponsible
and would be taken that way.
And at the very least it would be
unbelievably fucking offensive. But I,
that's what I think.
You guys tell me what you think.
I think if you just fucking around,
if you don't mean it in a malicious way,
it's, it's not racist.
You can be ignorant.
You can offend fucking people and
that type of stuff. But you know,
I really don't think that me playing
a game called older Asian is,
is racist.
Like some fucking guy in the clan going,
we need to get these
people out of the country.
They're beasts and that type
of shit. All right. I know.
Say we'll do the two dot. So you're, what
you're doing is a lighter form now. No,
I'm not. No, I'm not. You're an
oversensitive fucking cunt. All right?
And you're so far to the fucking left.
You're actually doing like this
McCarthyism, bleeding heart horse. Shit.
Go Fuck Yourself. Lighten
the fuck up. Okay.
Like when when I a black comic or
somebody's given me shit that white people
can't dunk a basketball or they
can't fucking dance, you know,
depending on how they say,
if they say it in a mean enough way,
I could get offended. I maybe could
get offended. But first of all,
my honestly going to sit there
and act like generally speaking,
white dudes can fucking dance.
Well,
white people in general or
that were dunking a basketball,
how many six foot 11
fucking guys have I seen
two and a half step and they just
fucking dislocate their shoulder,
hitting the ball in the front of
the fucking room. You know, I think,
you know what?
I think a lot of people they don't have,
they don't have a fucking sense of
humor either. So, uh, I don't know.
I think that guy last week at the Tony
Gwynn game, that's fucking hilarious.
That game that other guy played
where he sits there saying, you know,
he turns his back to the news and he
hears the crime and he tries to guess the
race is fucking hilarious.
This guy had three heads in his
refrigerator, crazy ass white guy,
crazy as cracker or whatever.
Like that's, it's funny.
Am I saying anything funny in this week?
I feel like I've just been ranting for
the past 20 fucking minutes. All right,
let's, let's plow ahead here. Oh, some
advice. All right. Advice Bill. Uh,
I've heard you mentioned a few times
that when you dedicated yourself to
following your dream,
you sa as a comedian,
you sacrificed everything to throw
yourself completely into comedy.
And then you usually say that on some
level it was easier for you to put
everything on the line because you were
young and it didn't have a lot to risk.
I'm 37 years old,
old jeans with a wife and two young
boys who are ages four and six.
A year ago I decided that
I wanted to be a comedian.
I've been doing open mikes consistently
for a year and I feel like I have real
potential.
I know it takes a lot of time to get good.
My problem is I can't
pay this month's rent.
I'm scared to get a better
fulltime job because it will take,
um, Mr Away. It'll take
me away from my dream.
A little typo there.
When you are older and have
responsibilities like kids and a wife,
how do you justify taking
risks to go for your dream?
All right, dude. All right.
This is a rough one for me to give
you advice on because I had never,
I've never been in that situation.
And also I never want
to talk somebody out of,
of doing what you want to do.
You should definitely keep doing standup
if that's what your heart's telling you
to do.
But as a man,
you cannot have a wife and kids and
not be able to pay the rent. All right?
Um,
you need to get a better full time job
and you just need to fucking work harder
and be more efficient when
you go out to the club.
If you've been hanging out a little
bit, don't hang out at all. And um,
you know, it's what you're
trying to do is not impossible,
but I will tell you this.
You can't
LACUSC kid hope. All right? The number
one job of a man is to fucking provide.
He have to provide for your
family. If you're not, you know,
I, you know, I, I, I don't want
to say this, but a lot at you,
the women look at you like you're
fucking useless. All right?
That's like them without a fucking vagina.
And I hate to reduce them as sex objects,
but that's just how we view you
fucking with you. But seriously, all
right, you have to provide, okay.
This is the thing I think, you
know, if your wife is cool,
she will understand that you
want to make this transition,
but you have to make it
as smooth as possible.
You can't be in a situation where you're,
where you can't pay the fucking rent.
All right? So, um,
I would get a better day job
if you had to at this time.
So you can pay the fucking rent and
then you can burn it at both ends and do
your stand up at night or whatever,
right?
And then eventually when you
start getting paid gigs with that,
then you can start to phase out the
fucking day job. All right? But, uh,
if I was you, I would sit down and
have a heart to heart with your wife.
So she gets where your head's at,
you know, and just tell her, look,
I really want to do this, but I understand
my job as a man, as I have to provide.
So I have, this won't happen
again. Yeah. You know,
you gotta have you got up, you got
to pay the fucking pills. Yeah.
Yeah. You know, you gotta pay
the fucking bills. It's just,
it's your job as a guy.
It really is.
I don't give a fuck about all is equal
rights in fucking independent women.
Put Your fucking titties
in the air or whatever.
How the fuck that Goddamn Song goes?
All right. Providing is our job.
That's our fucking job. We
have to, you have to do it.
Wait, you have to fucking do it. You know?
What do you fucking Steadman, you know?
I guess that's okay if you're, if you're,
if you're, you're, your chick is Oprah.
Speaking of which you ever
seen some of the operas houses.
I became fascinated with that when I did
that red bank and I was just looking at
those fucking houses,
the level of wealth,
and I just started typing
in Bill Gates' house,
Oprah's house and just like the most,
the richest people I could fucking
think of. Like Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ, m and m's house
looked up his for some reason.
Um, they're unbelievable.
These, the first of all,
they always like in like surrounding
them was always like a forest like that
maybe would have, they're so rich
that we have neighbors. Some of them,
some of them are, they've lived, you
know, crowded areas like Miami beach.
But some of these fucking people like
m and m's house look like a, like a,
I don't even know how to describe it.
It looked like a house.
That guy looks like an optical illusion.
Like it was a house. And then you give
us, he like in a movie, like where it,
all of a sudden a guy just
gets a hunchback. That's
what his house looked like.
It was a house. And then bomb, there's
another part of the house. And then,
then another house who's like,
he just took like these 20 fucking
houses and just stuck them all together.
That'd be a great house to have if,
if, if you were wanted by the law,
you know what I mean? You could literally
hide out in your own fucking house,
take by,
by at least another two and a half weeks
of freedom by the time they fucking
found you. You know, I don't know. I
don't know what the Hell I'm saying.
Um, so anyways, do that. That's, that's a
real tough situation. I hope you work out.
Don't give up on your
dream, but, uh, you know,
your wife is going to be way more
supportive if, if, if you're,
if you're paying the Goddamn, but you
gotta pay the bills. Got To pay the bills.
All right, here we go.
Next one. Hey, Bill. Uh,
as for advice a couple of months
ago about a friend of mine,
this was another brutal one.
Yeah.
But a friend of mine who's girlfriend
was having a kid and I was suspicious
about whether or not, um, it was his,
because he had gone and gotten checked
twice to see if he could have kids.
And the doctors said, no. Oh, I
remember this guy. Remember that one?
The doctor said this
guy got checked twice.
They said he couldn't have kids and all
of a sudden his girl was pregnant and
there was questions about her
being faithful. I remember this,
I remember this well, this is the
update of this. He said, well,
about five months into the pregnancy,
she miscarried.
So the problem kind of solved itself,
but it was a terrible thing to happen.
Now they are living together and I'm
still pretty positive she was cheating on
him and he's hanging onto the relationship
now through some sort of guilt
because of the lost child.
It just feels like my friend got one
pulled over on him and I really want to
talk to him about it, but I can't
find a good way to do it. Uh,
your podcasts rules and I help you come
to Edmonton sometime. It'll comic strip,
right? The comic strip in Edmonton. I'll
make my way up there at some point. Um,
dude, that is a brutal, brutal,
brutal, brutal situation. And uh,
it all depends on how you feel.
How are you going to be able to live
with yourself if you just say, listen,
this kid is just a moron.
He's my friend,
but he's a fucking moron because
that is an option. You know,
the good moment, you know, when he, uh,
they tell that joke in Italian and Deniro
says, what does it mean in, in pet?
She goes, it means he's, he's
content to be a jerk. You know,
what am I going to say?
My wife two times me that joke basically
about a guy who knows his wife's
fucking around on him and he just doesn't,
he just looks the other way.
He's content to be a jerk.
So that's what your friend is right now.
I know this emotions involved, so
there's, there is hope for them, but
you know,
he's,
he's fucking himself over.
So this is the deal.
If you can live with yourself and just
say, this guy's contend to be a jerk.
I'm not going to get in the fucking
middle of this because there's so many
obvious red flags here and this kid
is just choosing to ignore them.
Um, you could just say, fuck it.
He's content to be a fucking idiot,
but if you're not going to be
able to live with yourself,
then I would just sit down and
talk to them. All right? And,
um, hopefully listens to you and if
not, and he stops being your friend.
Um, there's nothing you
can fucking do about that.
And I got a feeling probably
seven or eight years from now,
you might get a phone call to him saying,
you know what, you are right. But the,
those are impossible situations.
Jesus Christ.
How the fuck would I handle that?
I would, uh, I would say
something. You know what? I would,
I would definitely say something,
but uh,
I don't know how to do that, to be honest
with you. I didn't fuck what I was sad.
I say, listen, you know, I'm friends
with you. We've been friends a long time.
That's what your buddy knows.
Something fucked ups coming. Let's see.
We've been friends a long time, right
pat? A lot of good times, right? You know,
you know,
you know that I've always been there
for you and I never tried to steer you
wrong. Right? Like I
think your girlfriend,
is it two timing?
Yeah.
How do you say that?
I would just rip the bandaid off.
Just say listen to something
I have to talk to you about.
We're friends and as a friend.
All right.
I can't stop thinking about this and it
would kill me to not bring this up to
you. I have to do this. I'm
not trying to be malicious.
I'm doing this because you're my
friend and then I would just say, look,
ah Jesus. I just had it narrowed. He
forgets how fucking difficult disease.
I would just be. It's
fucking ridiculous. Look,
you told me you couldn't have kids.
You went to the doctor twice.
You got tested.
They said you couldn't have kids yet.
This girl somehow got fucking pregnant.
Don't say fuck there yet.
Your, your, your girls
somehow got pregnant. Okay.
Then you just sort of stare at them.
I Dunno where to go from there.
All right.
My guts telling me that that
wasn't your fucking kid too.
That's a hard one to that one,
that,
that kid you just fucking cried
over that didn't get born.
I don't think it was yours. Anyways.
Ah, Jesus, dude, this is fucking brutal.
Brutal.
Um,
I would do,
this is what I would do.
I would do what I'm doing right now into
a mirror and just keep correcting it as
you go the same way I said,
okay. Don't say fuck there.
And then you back it up again and just
somehow figured out a way to say that I
think your girlfriend is a whore.
I don't think that she's being,
I don't think you're,
I don't think the woman that you're
with has been a 100% honest with you.
And I don't think
that she has been 100% faithful.
And my gut was telling me that that
wasn't your kid. See, that's brutal.
Taking it to there. All right. I think
you need to get out of this relationship.
I mean, I don't do it. I don't know how to
do it. I don't know how to fucking, yeah,
you stumped me. Stumped the Schwab. Me, I,
you know now like I know
everything obviously, but uh,
I usually can come up
with some sort of angle.
I don't know what the fuck to tell you
what for whatever you do,
don't write it down.
Don't put it in a letter
cause he'll probably show it
to her and then, then, uh,
then it'll just be brutal. The
fuck that. Don't, don't do that.
Just a huge, that's a uh, yeah.
I don't want to tell you dude,
that's a fucking brutal one.
Jesus. Does it work to just
say it? Listen, man, you're
best. We're best friends,
right? We can say anything to each
other. Yeah. I think your girlfriend, uh,
fuck somebody else without a condom and
got pregnant and said it was yours and
it's such a fucking psycho cunt that she
was about ready to let you take on the
responsibility and invest
that sort of time, your life.
She was content to throw away your
fucking life because she can't keep her
fucking legs on the ground and our
panties up around a fucking waste.
Do you understand me?
She's a fucking whore.
All right.
You went to two fucking doctors and
they said you can't get pregnant, dude.
How dumb are you?
Get your fucking head out of her fucking
vagina. Wake up. It's not your kid.
All right. That was God. God gave you
a fucking Mulligan. He gave me a pass.
All right. They go, you
want to get old? Jesus.
You want to get fucking religious about
it? Get out of the goddamn relationship.
Stop being such a fucking pussy.
Leave her
cry about it for fucking six weeks.
Whatever you gotta do,
go join a fucking gym and get on with
your fucking life and start wearing a
condom.
All right.
Now I know that team that we saw in the
first half is not the fuck attain that.
I know.
Well,
we got enough 30 minutes of fucking
football and I want you to get out there.
It proved to me that you could play and
I got the way. I know you could play.
That's what you do. You got there where
we go. It took me a minute to work it out.
You go fucking Vince Lombardi, grab, grab,
grab nobody tackling.
Okay.
She's a fucking whore. You gotta go
like Dad. You've got to build up. You've
got to start slow.
You got to start slow.
Oh my years are looking at relationships.
I don't think I have ever
in my life seen a woman.
So pull the fucking wall,
a pubes over somebody's fucking
eyes like I did at first half.
You know what I saw out there?
I saw bullshit. Just some,
I don't know how to do it. I'm
out. I don't know what to tell you.
I don't know what to tell you.
Tell that fucking kid.
He needs to make some halftime
adjustments. All right, pull the ripcord.
Get the fuck out of that gene as well.
See these,
these, these are the things
they, they don't, they don't,
they don't talk about these kinds of,
of, of women on, on those real shows.
They'll show women like that on Jerry
Springer and everyone looks like a retard,
so nobody gives a fuck. Right? But they
won't show those kinds of women on those.
Those real sort of issue shows when
they're just always talking about guys who
beat their women,
which they're horrible fucking people
and they should talk about them.
But why don't they ever talk about horse?
You know,
the only time they talk about whores
is just when they try to figure out why
there a whore.
You know,
dad didn't stick around fucking uncle
dental, Domo, you know, whatever.
They always got a fucking reason. Now
he's got a goddamn excuse. You know?
Maybe they're just horse.
You ever think of that?
I think there's already women out there
as a woman out there when I want to know
this.
Okay,
this is totally anonymous and I'm not
judging you because I'm a male whore
myself. All right? I want to know this.
Is there a woman out there with dad
stuck around? You had a great family.
You weren't touched in any funny way.
You went to school,
you know you are girl scouts,
you did all the right things,
but you just love Dick.
And not only do you love Dick,
you love a bunch of different dicks
and you are in a relationship,
but every once in awhile you just got
to go out and go back somebody else
because you're fucking bored basically.
Are you wired like a man?
That's what I want to know.
Okay. And you can be totally
honest. Let's examine.
Let's examine that because I don't even
think it's fair to just brand them all
horse.
I don't,
I think some of them are raw,
actually really intelligent and they've
actually sat and contemplated it,
Jeff or you know,
done.
What I've done is justify
their piece of shit moves.
Ah, you know something. This is the time
when I really should just have a guest.
I don't have a guest. I got to have
more guests on this fucking podcast.
What do a what? Do what do? What do you,
what do you want from me? All right.
You guys want some youtube
videos for this week? Huh?
Have you slumped over and
your cubicles left yet?
Have you done that with five minutes
left and you fucking day. All right.
Youtube videos for the week. Uh,
the truth about Facebook privacy,
I actually haven't a
chance to watch this yet.
This was suggested to me by somebody
close to me, so I just put that on there.
I hear it go when fireworks fail,
this guy shoots off one that should,
it should have gone on after
the fucking Boston pops.
And he basically shoots it
off in his own neighborhood.
And for some reason it goes off about,
oh, I don't know about maybe 30,
35 feet in the air, a
bunch of houses around. Um,
here's another good one. Angry
skateboarder. Here's a hockey one.
Blonde Jaga is in Jaromir Jaeger
and a band called a mute math.
Great musicians, great albums, albums,
and they have a fucking insane drummer.
Oh, speaking of which people,
speaking of which, um,
I've been taking my drumming to a new
level, to a brand new fucking for me.
For me, I still suck.
But after plateauing, I,
uh, I just sort of, I got fucking add,
right as you could tell from my podcast,
hey,
have you noticed that I started to make
a point than something else reminds me
of something else. And then maybe I'll
drive over to the left for a while.
You know,
I can't sit still,
I can't focus unless,
uh,
unless something really fucked
up is happening. That's the only,
they something really fucked up has to
be happening before you will get 100% of
my attention,
you know?
I don't know why, but
that's how it is. So, uh,
with my playing drums, I'm the
same way. I'm always learning,
trying to learn five different
things at the same fucking time.
You know, I'll do this for
like three minutes and I'll
do this for three minutes.
I'll do this for two minutes and
then, and then I'll fuck, you know,
and then I have three new things that
I'm trying to learn and rather than just
learning one and getting it
down, I don't, and, and uh,
it's something I've known for a while.
I watched this guy, Mike Johnston,
who has these great
lessons, any, he had this,
he basically mapped
out on how to practice.
He teed show you something and it was,
it was pattern.
You get the pattern down and then you
bring it up to speed and then you'd move
it all around the kit. So it's
just patterns, speed, movement,
ABC one, two, three could, couldn't have
got any more basic, but my fucking add,
I couldn't fucking do it.
So I finally decided I was fucking sick.
I was sick of this shit.
So I just decided to focus on a couple
of things and one of them was at Joe Joe
May or fucking thing
with your bass drum foot.
It's something I saw Steve Gadd do.
A lettuce is really for drum heads here.
Steve Gadd Duwan is up close video a
long time ago and I sat down and I fuck
with that thing after borderline
messing with it for a year and a half.
I sat down for like like three days in
a row and religiously worked on it and
was blown away by how much faster I got
my foot as far as being able to do three
hits in a row because I'm Ah,
who's kidding who?
Any Zeppelin fans out there?
There's two licks,
three licks that I've been
trying to get down. Okay.
I finally be able to get the good
times, bad times, 16th note, triplets.
I can do those fucking things up to
speed. I can play good times, bad times,
but when he does the three in a
row like that, licky does on a,
I can't quit you babe.
When he does the three in a
row there and out on the tiles,
there's a lick in there where I think,
I think I'm hearing three
and then the want and soc,
which is a big debate on how to this is
so fucking is I'm really going to lose a
lot of listeners here,
but there's a big debate on
how the fuck he plays that.
Does he pay bone that the debt, the debt
or done that? The debt that the debt,
I think he does three after the snare,
he and uh,
on the to us is so fucking stupid.
Why am I talking about this anyways?
What that Jojo Mayor Shit.
Okay.
They play that at about 101
hundred two beats per minute,
but that Jojo mayor thinks I can play
that lick with the three hits on the Bass
Drum after the snare on too.
I can play that at 90 beats per minute.
MMM.
Permanent. Yeah. I can play
it at data at this point.
So I'm within fucking striking
distance of that after, you know,
fucking with this thing for a year
and a half, finally just sitting down.
Um, and if drummers out there
wasn't any sort of advice,
I can show you what I did because I'm
just really nervous that this is just,
I mean, it's already bad enough. I
have people in Europe listens to me,
go off on American sports
and in Australia and shit.
For me to actually sit here
and describing drum licks,
it's pretty fucking pathetic. But, um,
anyways, I think I'm winding down here.
I got to make sure I edit this thing
and get this thing up on time and I also
have to make sure, oh my God.
Oh fuck. What time is it?
I got to go three 15. I gotta be down
at the fucking place to buy four. Fuck.
All right. I gotta go.
Thanks for listening to the
podcast. Uh, God bless all.
You don't take any shit.
Go Fuck Yourself. See it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].